ما رايناه في النيجر هو عرقله لنظام
الدستوري ونحن كالعديد من البلدان في جميع
انحاء افريقيا مصممون على اعاده النظام
الدستوري للنيجر
اخبروا العلم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم قاده الانقلاب في النيجر يرفضون
دخول وفد يمثل ايكواس والاتحاد الافريقي
والامم المتحده وتقارير عن نشرهم قوات
اضافيه تحسبا للتدخل الاجنبي المحتمل في
حين يؤكد بلنكا للجزيره اجراء اتصالات
استعاده النظام الدستوري والمبعوثه
الامريكيه تجري لقاءات في نيامي وصفتها
بالصعبه
كيف تعلن سقوط قتلى في قصف صاروخي روسيا
على فندق ووحدات سكنيه شرقيه البلاد
وموسكو تقول انها استهدفت مقرا لقياده
العمليات الاوكرانيه هناك الجيش الاوكراني
يعلن تنفيذ عمليه خاصه جنوب نهر دنيبر
والسلطات المواليه لروسيا تؤكد انها
افشلتها
وزيره الخارجيه الاستراليه بيني ونك تقول
ان الحكومه تتجه لاستخدام مصطلح الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله واعتبار المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه غير قانونيه بحسب القانون
الدولي مشيره الى ان حكمتها ستعود الى
موقف الحكومات السابقه باستخدام لغه اكثر
صراحه بشان الاحتلال والخارجيه الفلسطينيه
تعتبره تطورا ايجابيا
مرصد كوبر نيكوس للمناخ التابع للاتحاد
الاوروبي يعلن ان شهر يوليو تموز المنصرم
سجل باعتباره الشهر الاعلى حراره في
التاريخ على مستوى العالم مشيرا الى ان
درجات الحراره العالميه خلاله تجاوزت
مستويات ما قبل الثوره الصناعيه بواحد
فاصله خمسه درجات مئويه الى اللقاء